so when I was like 11 and then I took a
break when I was like 18 then went back
to it and then came here and then he
ruined my life how how can you convince
you opened the light for you you ruined
my life
[Music]
welcome back to another amazing episode
of off the record with the careful boys
uh we've got a phenomenal guest today
we've got Hannah in the not hot City I
was gonna say hot seat it's not a hot
seat we've got Hannah here today
everybody clap your [__] hands sounds
pretty harsh huh
what are you going for there what does
it sound like she's like a [__]
does this sound fake or does it sound
like an actual region oh no he sounds
like an actual region it's actually
really really good oh what region are
you being sarcastic
I'm like an idiot
pool
yeah a whole video everybody's got to go
with their Posh accents okay all right
oh yeah do a British accent see where
that goes
we should have had Hawk here we should
have had Hawk here and then Hannah's all
like get this fake ass British boy out
of here Hawks is the most part show he
gets made in front of by other British
people and it sounds fake he's Oxford
all the way it sounds so fake for some
reason he should be reading audio books
imagine him doing Dickinson oh yeah
that'll be lovely or just directions on
your GPS are you pretty good like for
example
um obviously within America we're like
familiar with like American lingo or
accents whether it be like Southern or
like you know from the hood or like
whatever or like Italian obviously we
got our Italian unlocked right but uh
same with with British are you capable
of like doing like clear Regional
accents for like me yeah as in like
faking it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
exaggerating or mocking it yeah yeah
like a joke
now I'm really like genuinely [__] like
you sound like you're from London
yeah that's good London yeah honestly
probably better than my London accent
London Mike mine's terrible I can't do
it I can speak like this what about your
Vietnamese one yeah
internet
of the video I'll do it later though
it's pretty good okay I taught her well
yeah what are like what are like the uh
when you hear types of accents like it
denotes like almost like a class
all of them if you hear someone and they
don't sound like Hawk they have a
regional accent they're common as [__]
like just check your pocket zip your bag
up
so Hawks not common her ass and Hawks is
queen's English queen's English when he
walks by you get more money in your
wallet
it just multiplies
pounds pounds it's all quid quid 300
quid I just quit in my pocket imposter
so like so his accent that he does
beautifully what region would he be from
[__] Narnia or some [__]
he knows Mr tubness but if hog doesn't
say hello Gardener I don't know what
kind of Posh is that he's just like RP
standard seven what's RP I actually
don't know what it stands for oh gosh
Royal parchment
did you grow up at the palace oh Royal
Palace what do you think of uh the new
king are you like a big fan like what
are your thoughts that's a great first
question
as an ignorant American you know asking
questions what do I think
I think we should have gone a bit more
French on them a long time ago
Slaughter no yeah Guillotine style do it
nice storming the Bastille yes oh yeah
that would be great that would probably
get more views in The Royal Wedding just
all the iris
they're the ones I hate there storming
the palace get in there get rid of them
yeah why not that's because she's Welsh
she's not really yeah we're not into
that stuff what is what is that what
does that mean when you're like Welsh
enough Wells people got colonized by
England and they got forced to speak
English close enough yeah close enough
so you have a different language that
you speak do you know what the Welsh do
yeah but you don't know how I know a
little bit but don't ask me to do it
because I'll get told off because it's
not good it's like a sensitive subject
it's like similar to how in Hawaii they
came over and they were like no longer
allowed to speak Hawaiian and now
they're trying to bring it back oh so a
lot of Welsh people do speak it but it's
like a sensitive thing and sometimes if
you ask a Welsh person they get real
like
it's like you're saying they're less
Welsh if they don't speak or they feel
guilty for not speaking oh interesting
oh I have no idea I really relate to the
Hawaiians which you know that's why I
live there yeah and become local same
struggle same struggle it's very very
similar is it really common for uh Welsh
people to be predominantly like redheads
it's Celtic Celtic yeah that's
indigenous whites yeah yeah with the OG
white the native whites
princess Kimiko over here
[Laughter]
Celtics are generally redheads more of
them yeah really Kelly doesn't really
mean much though it's just a bunch of
people that moved across Europe and
landed in the UK but it's like different
tribes the Boston Celtics like that
they're leprechauns that's okay I do I
don't know you smell Celtic with the KRC
that's [__] good though dude
Celtics I don't accept any of the Celts
in America though I'm gonna say it
you're not us not even Larry Bird
what about Kevin Garnett he's from
Indiana
I'll take Conan and I'll take Steve
Green that's it Steve Green oh he's
considered a redhead
but he's like he thinks he's Irish
he thinks he's Irish so we'll let him
how can you tell what is what's the
German about him nobody looks more
German than Stephen
[Laughter]
Oktoberfest scared I could picture him
more than that I picture him more than
that than like Irish wear nobody looks
more German that's crazy that you can
see with those eyes because for me like
I yeah for Asians I could oh that's
super Korean or super whatever yeah
because we're used to it right but for
me like white people just like white
people whoa he's like oh you're German
he's German he's German as the queen
bless him but he thinks he's Irish queen
of Germany
the whole royal family is German ish
except Meghan Markle though huh I like
her yeah she's still good style nice
hair documentary was weird but yeah it
was and she married a ginger so I'm good
with her
if you'll accept a ginger man I have to
like you yeah because not many people
will you're one of us right I mean maybe
because Prince could have something to
do yeah that's right I forgot he
probably has some extra leverage the
most gender gingers do still Ginger
though still Ginger that's why he went
after a princess uh Kimiko over here
look at that that's sexy though that
this is hers it is
from the outside like how do you view
America like what is like America how
smart or like
you specifically yeah start with me
start from like appearances and then
like first impressive oh just for hit
yeah yeah I know one thing I know I know
one thing we don't have enough time
Europeans don't wear hats like that not
unless you're a hipster in East London
um they don't wear baseball
oh no my head my head was cold so I put
it on this morning East London hipster
that's dope you don't get to respond
though she just has to keep oh yeah
oh yeah to be fair he's very forgettable
do you think he spoke English at all no
I didn't I did not realize this guy's
fresh off the boat
I mean I thought that
it was a really fun game
oh I'm having so much fun this is great
so so let's let's say back to it's more
of a Lombard's generic question of uh
generic opinions of Americans and then
your personal discoveries of Americans
yeah what do the Brits think of us and
then what do you think of us yeah you
don't want to know the answer
I don't know
people are concerned when they knew I
was dating an American they're what they
were concerns how are they concerned
with your mental health kind of yeah
they were like hasn't hit rock bottom
yet like you've not hit 30 you've still
got options you've not completely over
the hill
what's the equivalent
it's kind of like they just you don't
have to
the stratation
and at the time with those the Donald
Trump stuff
it wasn't great it wasn't great they
were deeply concerned they don't think
uh did it change when they saw him it
changed when they saw his Instagram
following they were like ah that'll do
he's into crypto cool yeah oh but they
were concerned they commented on that
more than him being Asian
but that he's American yeah they refer
to him as the American wow how does that
feel that's great right we call him the
jab around here dude today's video is
brought to you by DraftKings are you
ready for the biggest Sunday in sports
draftking Sportsbook an official sports
betting partner of Super Bowl 57 has all
the Super Bowl action that you need new
customers can bet just five dollars and
get 200 and free bets instantly wow plus
all customers can get in on the Super
Bowl 57 excitement with DraftKings happy
hour super boosts check the DraftKings
Sportsbook app every day between 6 p.m
to 9pm Eastern Standard Time to see what
prop bet will be boosted have you guys
been following it's getting crazy Chiefs
versus the Eagles okay we got Patrick
Mahomes versus Jalen hurts two guys that
have had a MVP season two stack teams
who's gonna win I don't know it's gonna
be super exciting can't wait to watch it
so download the DraftKings sports book
app and use the code off the Record new
customers can bet five dollars on Super
Bowl 57 and get 203 bets instantly only
at DraftKings Sportsbook with code off
the Record minimum age and eligibility
restrictions apply void in Ohio see the
show notes for details and it's never
looked more Japanese at this moment yeah
dude
I didn't know like the these small
little cultural new because sometimes I
feel like we're so connected to the UK
just from the content we consume and all
that that it just feels like America in
Europe yeah yeah and then like
I just didn't know certain things like
how like there's so many mixed
relationships there and it's really new
here so it's like a wow thing like it's
like wow people are just dating
interracially and I was like because all
of my family members and like friends
were like is her family cool with it
because that's always the thing that
they ask is like is that are they cool
with like dating outside you know and
whatever and then she's like I already
have like so many other ethnic like she
has African uncles and like Indian and
all that so it's like no one cause yeah
and then didn't you say something about
like the the whole
there there's been Nobles and stuff and
all that yeah that's history I mean it's
never been illegal do you know what I
mean like here it was illegal right you
weren't allowed to do it it never was
like Othello was written in what 1400s
he's a black guy married to a white girl
that's Shakespeare [__] like this spear
[__] uh you got a Brit on here now so
you gotta talk about Shakespeare yeah
yeah I heard of Othello I thought it was
some Greek philosopher [__] me too
that's why the pieces are black and
white is that what boxes are in the game
Othello I've never even played that
before yeah yeah what's that game
yeah but I mean it was still mad races
back in the day but okay so so that's a
little bit tied to Joe but what are some
other broader perspectives that the the
Brits have of of us us yeah talk about
the [__] you want yeah [__] about
Americans and at the end of the day you
told me don't hold back all of us here
are immigrants right Colleen
at some point at some point see we're
all well I guess we got no loyalties
you're like the freshest immigrant so we
should be talking [__] to you yeah get
out of my country yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah get out of my country
the thing is all the stereotypes the
British have about the Americans the
stained stereotypes that the rest of
Europe has about the Brits oh like what
so like kind of dumb culturally ignorant
don't speak any other languages food
sucks food sucks that's not true
all that kind of stuff and then the rest
of Europe thinks that Britain is like
dumb uncultured overweight so it's like
you always have to shift it along but
that was what we thought and it's kind
of true people here are bigger I gained
like 20 pounds when I came to America oh
yeah congrats what do you think it was
in the McDonald's it was that yeah okay
make that guy she was a vegetarian
before she met me no way for like a
decade dude a decade so when I was like
11 and then I took a break when I was
like 18 then went back to it and then
came here and then he ruined my life how
how did they convince you opened the
[__] light for you you ruined my life
no you love chicken and beef how did he
convince you to eat that I didn't she
did it herself oh yeah you [__] mad
yeah he gave me street meat some guy
just treat me yeah it was like midnight
in Mexico
in Mexico he got fajitas and he goes
here you go Hannah I got some for you
and because she's a polite Brit she's
not an American that goes I'm vegan you
son of a [__] she's more like oh really
that's nice can't be rude oh really and
it was bad oh it was ended it was like
midnight the guy had like the last piece
of meat he put it on the grill
did you get diarrhea not from that we
did though we got like what a week at
the Marriott the Marriott it was coming
up from a nice place yeah yeah it was
gross too and we had one bathroom and we
shared it oh no and it was coming up
both ends
I got that one must have brought you
guys closer though yeah yeah it's really
actually sexy
it was the most sexy it reaches a point
that it just gets hot
sweat coming down his face pushing I was
like some man it's a man what about
favorite things about America free
refills that's beautiful
why I take that for granted that's so
good they just bring it to you I'm like
yeah constantly so good you could be
like hey what the you just point I'm so
sorry I'm so sorry yeah you can be rude
yeah you better look
top off yeah
come on man
free refills I love that you said you're
a shocked of how the service is here
sanity how the service is in what ways
Insanity it's like you own them
oh it's like there's no free will
anymore if you're in the service
[__] you just do whatever the [__]
people want you to do you have to act
like there's one person in the world who
has money and that's that customer it's
barely two dollars and doesn't tip we
don't say sire or anything though you
basically do I mean it is it is called
the service industry he's a means who
are no yeah what the expectation of what
people have to do in this country is
ridiculous just as much as the
expectation of how much we have to tip
for that service not everyone does
though that's true yeah what's it like
over there let's say let's say you're uh
you work at a restaurant can I get me
some potatoes yes you can
and then what's the what's it how do you
have to react here can I get some
potatoes God damn it yeah you bow
[Laughter]
at the balls while they order the food
just to make sure they feel the
connection they feel good give it a
little tickle then you bring them the
potatoes right and the potatoes aren't
good you have to finish the job Jack
them off they come and that's how you
get it
yeah
that's nice yeah that's the service on
June B right it's someone's going
straight to Hawaii that's just you're
making her cut balls all day that's why
we're the number one top selling store
has he been lying to me because I've
been coughing balls like oh no that's an
American I think he groomed you
you're as bad as Andrew Tate Jesus
Christ
what are some good slang words that we
could use to insult people that like
Brits you you [__] like how do we really
cut to the core of one British person
your American like what's worse than
what's worse than that you Yankee what's
worse than that it's more tone you've
got to really drop it no humor in it
[__] oh yikes
yeah yeah the lip the lip Rays I can't
even are we gonna get flagged for that
is that 100 by the British flag
people don't see the call Value don't
care God not that weird everyone here
hates that word we love what word [__] I
like that word yeah I think it's cool
we're not allowed to say it on public
and stuff it's a it's like a major curse
word isn't it America's hate it can you
say that word on like British TV and
radio I think you can say after anything
after 9pm you can pretty much say what
you want whoa that's sweet that's pretty
cool they got like a anti-con curfew
yeah it's for the kids yeah because
they're going to sleep that's amazing we
don't have none of that
so no humor just cold say it yeah
there's even like a smidge a few minutes
you lost it because we say [__] why
don't like oh you little [__] yeah
what's the number one thing that your
family is like jealous of you for for
being here free refills free refills
cup of water I always bring it up when
you talk to her like man how are those
free refills yeah you like them wait
they gave you a free soda on that wait
you already paid you already paid for
one and you get three refills
and they just don't stop you could keep
drinking oh my God this is a crazy
that concept must have been wild though
and like waiters
so you're stealing
so you pay for one soda and you could
get two or three or four or as many as
you can it's weird that's the American
dream dude and we get free napkins oh
you do actually that is that is actually
a really big thing when you like go to
other places and you don't have napkins
there and you're just like oh [__] yeah
I don't know what to do what do you guys
do go in the bathroom in a restaurant
okay you pull the [__] paper towel
out and then sometimes they don't do a
good job so like four of them fall into
the trash can AKA like these ones over
here yeah you're talking about your own
place do you get those clean ones stuff
them back in or you go I didn't see why
would you stop it back in because
they're clean I already like landed in
the trash are afraid of the environment
so we're all on the same page then yeah
I'm not gonna do that but I felt guilty
I feel guilty that I saw I saw something
happen I saw like the mom leave the kids
behind it I didn't say hey Mommy left
the kids like to see something say
something yeah yeah let's go up I didn't
see that and let's walk away well I
would at least throw it in the trash I
wouldn't put it back in oh it's in the
charger oh it's in the trash fine if
it's only four pieces I'll find use for
each one yeah and what if it was from
the roll thing you have to [__] roll
it back in
that's nice you're a good guy
all right last [__] talking point about
America go ahead last one give us one
more one more give us a good one dude
what's the stupidest thing we do yeah
yeah the stupidest thing
politics yeah are we doing it wrong the
whole thing we just have it all wrong
it's too long six months come on now
what's six months our campaign or uh
well it starts a year before actually
it's once a year before six weeks it
never really ends yeah they're still
campaigning through through their
presidency right for for approval yeah
yeah we do six weeks start finish done
done
over we don't want to listen to them
talk that much yeah join me and it's a
lot of nothing too huh so much nothing
yeah that bothers me deeply so we look
pretty stupid all into it and following
the news and like yeah I can see that
you know they're Prime Ministers they
[__] battle it out like they debate
it all and they and then they [__]
talk [__] with the parties and it's like
real quick so are the debates there
actually debates
because you know here they're not real
debates like it's just like we make them
wear wigs and stuff it's fun you know we
keep it like dude we gotta wear wigs
then huh they still do that oh yeah we
do a lot of that oh yeah no I mean like
we they only debate during the
presidential campaign right they debate
during their term when there's topics
yeah and it's like oh and you got
another person going oh like Canada does
it the same way when Trudeau was like
talking about the truckers and [__] and
then they just pop up and I was like wow
look at this and she's like the British
one's better and I'm like what
she said the Canadian ones like British
one like elementary school kids per like
practicing to do it like Parliament so I
was like what so then I saw the British
one I'm like dang they go crazy
you know it's funny though I was
recently in Hong Kong and you know how
like obviously the British occupied Hong
Kong for 100 years blah blah blah so in
their Judicial System even these like
Chinese dudes with the captain crunches
funny dude in the whole thing and it's
like it's still entertaining that shit's
real I used to be so confused with my
mom would be watching the J channel that
Kenston uses soap operas and I'll be
like why are they wearing oh yeah they
do they still they got it's clear like
the black hair is still coming out like
they don't put it on like as a real job
yeah they're not trying to trick it they
put it on like a hat yeah yeah it's like
I must that white it's like it's like
look at the Quaker Oats guy